So the answer is no. That it does not and the key reason why it does not is
there's no base case. Without a base case, it's
not a recursive definition. What it is, is a
circular definition. And that means that it actually doesn't
give us any answers. Because we'll never finish here
right. The only way that we've defined popularity whether
you look at that mathematical expression or the python code.
Always involves calling popularity again. And we are never going
to get to a point where we can stop. That we
are going to keep calling popularity for different people. If
we think of doing this for our friend graph, well here's
what would happen. If we wanted to know the popularity
of Charlie. Well, we have to look at all the people
who are friends with Charlie. So, that means that the popularity
of Diana, the popularity of Edgar, and the popularity of Fred.
But, for each of those, we need to compute their
popularities. To the popularity of Diana, that's going to be
equal to the popularity of Alice. So, now we're here,
but we need keep going. And, the popularity of Alice
is the popularity of Edgar plus the popularity of Bob.
But we need to keep going. We still need
the popularity of Edgar well, that's the popularity of Fred.
And we need the popularity of Bob, which is the popularity
of Fred. And we need the popularity of Fred, which
is the popularity of Charlie, plus the popularity of Bob.
So, this is not okay, right? The problem is, we
started trying to figure out the popularity of Charlie, we did
all this work following these links backward. And now, to
solve it, we need to know the popularity of Charlie.
But that's what we were trying to solve. So
this is not a recursive definition. To be a good recursive
definition, we have to end up with a simpler version of the problem. And never
go back to the one that we started with. The way we've defined it, we get
back to the one that we started with.
We haven't made any progress. We're never going to
get an answer. Charlie will be very unhappy
because we'll never know how popular he is.